a remote village in Greenland is
threatened by a massive iceberg this
morning video captured a large piece of
the iceberg breaking off and then
crashing into the water last week now
there are fears another breakaway chunk
could trigger a tsunami evacuations have
already started in the town of inner
suet that's home to almost 200 people
Mark Phillips who's in London looks at
the threat that researchers are blaming
on climate change mark good morning to
you good morning well we all know it's
been a hot summer and not just in North
America and here in Europe but it's also
been warm somewhere where it matters
even more in the Arctic for us the
consequences are potential and long-term
but they are immediate
in a month small little place it's huge
it's beautiful and when the massive
iceberg that's grounded off the tiny
Greenland fishing port of an R so it
starts to break up it's dangerous the
village on Greenland's West Coast is
home to only 169 people and more than 30
of them have already been moved to
higher ground because when the iceberg
calves when chunks of it fall into the
sea powerful waves surge into the harbor
if the warm weather means the Berg
breaks up faster or worst of all rolls
over the town could be flooded
Greenland's ice is on the move
this is the Helheim glacier on the East
Coast and that's a chunk half the size
of Manhattan breaking off in a
spectacular event captured last month by
a husband and wife climate science team
from New York University Deniz and David
Holland of NYU have spent decades
studying Greenland's ice and have never
seen anything like it
is this an event that we're gonna be
seeing more and more of warmer air or
perhaps even more important warmer water
leads to very rapid disintegration of
ice and icebergs are a very unstable
structure the calving of icebergs off
Greenland's glaciers isn't new
the question is whether it's speeding up
because the Arctic seas are warming
and what that means on a trip there are
several years ago that it was happening
was obvious how quickly these icebergs
break off the glaciers and how fast they
flowed out to sea and melt will
determine how quick sea levels rise
across the planet this is in theory
these are the real consequences of
climate change in handy frozen packets
these Berg's the Helheim glacier that
monster stuck off an are suet they are
the future those residents of an are
suet are watching that Berg and watching
the thermometer and so should we
Gale got it mark it's beautiful scenery
it is it is but it's also dangerous you
know this is a population of 200 what
happens next when you're gonna deal with
larger cities and I love that we have
the old Marx old piece because you know
chose that over time the predictions are
coming yeah also grow beard yeah our
thanks to mark in London